La cousine de Valentine, elle ne peut pas être immortelle, parce qu’elle est morte.
C’est qu’il y a de la place dans le congel, on n’a qu’à la mettre là-dedans en attendant.
J’adore Valentine. Mais faut vraiment qu’elle arrête de faire des blagues sur sa famille.
Surtout quand ils sont dissimulés illégalement dans le congélateur de la maison.
On ne devrait pas nourrir le chien ? Il n’a pas l’air bien là.
Je l’ai nourri tout à l’heure, mais il n’a pas l’air dans son assiette.
Il s’entendait bien avec Shirley. ils faisaient de longues balades ensemble.
C’est ça tu penses ?
Les animaux sont des êtres sensibles. Même la justice l’a reconnue dernièrement, ça m’étonne que tu poses la question en fait.
Alors oui, mais non.
En 2015, sous la pression d’une pétition de 30 Millions d’amis qui avait recueilli 800k signatures quand même,
l’animal a été reconnu comme “un être doué de sensibilité”.
Révolution juridique s’exclame, plein de gens.
Les animaux ne sont plus considérés comme une table ou une chaise !
Maintenant, on les respectera beaucoup plus !
Sauf que globalement, c’est un peu des bêtises.
En fait, l’article 515-14 du Code Civil nous dit “les animaux sont des êtres vivants doués de sensibilité.
Sous réserve des lois qui les protègent, les animaux sont soumis au régime des biens”.
Ok.
Donc on a rajouté « être vivant doué de sensibilité »,
mais à côté, on constate que l'animal est toujours régi sous le régime des biens...
Ce qui était déjà le cas avant.
Concrètement, rien n'a changé.
La question déjà qu'il faut se poser c'est : un « être doué de sensibilité », qu'est-ce-que ça signifie, juridiquement parlant ?
Bon, à notre époque actuelle, on sait que les animaux sont effectivement doués de sensibilité,
ils ont peur, ils peuvent être tristes, joyeux, ils témoignent de l’affection, on n’a plus trop besoin de le prouver.
Mais est-ce-que c’est vraiment pertinent de le rajouter dans le Code civil ?
Le Sénat avait d’abord refusé cette modification, en avançant que “le Code Civil se borne à expliquer ce qui est juste ou injuste ;
autorisé ou interdit.”
Ca peut sembler un peu froid et très factuel de prime abord,
mais le Code civil n’est pas là pour influencer notre morale,
même si c'est évidemment notre morale qui influence beaucoup notre droit.
Mais de là à l’inscrire dans le Code civil,
c’est encore autre chose !
Ce qui nous intéresse en droit, c'est donner une classification aux animaux pour leur appliquer des règles de droit précises.
Or, dire que l'animal est un être doué de sensibilité, ça ne fait pas beaucoup avancer les choses...
surtout si on conclut à la fin que l'animal est toujours soumis au régime des biens.
Mais j'y viens, ça veut dire quoi soumis au régime des biens ?
En droit, un bien, c'est une chose sur laquelle une personne détient des droits, à savoir :
le droit d'en être le propriétaire ;
le droit de l'utiliser ;
et le droit d'en récolter les fruits.
Donc effectivement, vous êtes le propriétaire de votre chat,
vous avez le droit de l’utiliser et s’il a une portée, vous pouvez garder ou donner les chatons.
Votre animal remplit ces critères !
Dans notre droit français, et ce qui était déjà le cas du droit romain dont notre droit s’est beaucoup inspiré,
on fait une distinction entre d’un côté les personnes et de l’autre,
les biens : c’est ce qu’on appelle la summa divisio.
La différence principale entre une personne et un bien,
c'est qu'une personne dispose de ce qu'on appelle la personnalité juridique.
cela signifie qu'elle a des droits et des devoirs, elle peut conclure des contrats etc.
Les biens, comme une chaise par exemple, n'ont pas de personnalité juridique… parce-que oui les chaises ne peuvent pas conclure de contrats. Jusque là, tout semble logique.
Donc, si on ne veut plus considérer que les animaux sont des biens,
on doit les qualifier de personnes... avec tout ce que cela implique !
Exercice de pensée : si les animaux étaient des personnes (ou assimilées comme des personnes),
pourrions-nous en posséder librement, sans leur consentement ?
Il faut pousser le raisonnement jusqu'au bout pour comprendre le choix du législateur et pourquoi il soumet l’animal au droit des biens.
Parce que si on ne pousse pas le raisonnement jusqu’au bout, ça va créer des incohérences, ce qui n'est pas acceptable en droit.
Ces incohérences risqueraient d'entraîner des vides juridiques, c'est à dire des situations qui ne sont pas régies par le droit.
Et ça, c’est dangereux car on ne sait pas trop à quelle sauce on va être mangé et puis, c’est coton pour le juge qui doit prendre la décision derrière.
Alors vous allez me dire, mais y a pas que des personnes et des biens en droit,
y a d’autres catégories.
Et vous auriez raison.
En droit, on appelle ça les catégories sui generis, des cas un peu particuliers si vous voulez.
Et l’exemple le plus emblématique, ce serait celui du fœtus.
Parce que oui, dans notre droit français, le foetus n’est pas une personne, au sens où il n’a pas de personnalité juridique.
Il y avait eu un cas il y a plusieurs années d’une femme enceinte de 6 mois qui a subi un grave accident de voiture.
Malheureusement, dans cet accident, elle perd son fœtus.
Elle a intenté un procès à la personne qui avait provoqué l’accident sur le fondement de l’homicide involontaire.
Et les juges ne retiennent pas l’homicide involontaire parce que pour cela,
il faudrait considérer que le foetus était une personne au sens juridique du terme
et j’insiste vraiment sur le fait que c’est au sens juridique.
Le foetus n’obtiendra cette personnalité juridique que s’il naît vivant et viable.
Le foetus n’est donc pas une personne mais ce n’est pas un bien non plus, et vous en conviendrez,
il y a pourtant bien des règles juridiques qui protègent le foetus,
par exemple, on ne peut pas  faire des expérimentations de clonage dessus et passé un certain délai, on ne peut plus avorter sans avis médical.
C’est donc une catégorie sui generis, loin de la distinction personne / bien,
et ça n’empêche pas pour autant une protection renforcée.
Revenons à nos moutons.
Pour reprendre les arguments avancés par certaines personnes,
il est complètement faux de considérer que l'animal est un meuble, au même titre qu'une table.
En fait, c’est peut-être là que réside tout le problème.
On fait une confusion entre le mot “meuble” au sens commun du terme
et le mot “meuble” dans sa dimension juridique.
Un meuble au sens commun, c’est une chaise, une armoire.
Non obstant, au sens juridique,
un meuble c’est tout simplement quelque chose qui peut être déplacé.
Le terme juridique de “meuble” s'oppose tout simplement à celui “d’immeuble”.
L'immeuble ne peut pas être déplacé, comme une maison par exemple ; tandis que les meubles, on peut le faire.
D’autant plus qu’accorder le statut de “personne” ou assimilé poserait un problème de taille, pour ce qui concerne…
la responsabilité !
Hé oui ! Que se passe-t-il si votre chien divague dans le quartier et mord quelqu’un ? C’est vous qui en êtes le propriétaire.
Donc si la victime vous poursuit en justice à cause de la morsure, on va engager votre responsabilité.
C’est vous qui allez dédommager financièrement la victime.
En droit, c’est donc un régime spécifique en matière de responsabilité,
on l’appelle “la responsabilité du fait des animaux”.
Il est très difficile d’imaginer un autre régime applicable à ce cas précis.
Quand bien même les animaux seraient extrêmement protégés, avec un statut très particulier,
on ne pourra jamais les considérer comme “responsables” au sens juridique du terme.
A moins que l’on veuille faire revenir les procès des animaux, qui ont vraiment existé…
Parce-qu’au 15e siècle, on avait jugé une truie et ses petits porcelets pour le meurtre d’un enfant !
Alors pour info,  ça finit mal, la truie a été condamnée à mort mais ses porcelets ont été acquittés.
Oui.
Tenir les animaux pour responsables, ce serait considérer qu’ils ont une vision du bien et du mal,
qui change selon les pays et surtout, qui est très ethnocentrée.
On ne pourra jamais se passer de ce régime de responsabilité,
et je ne vois pas en quoi il entrerait en conflit avec des avancées pour le droit des animaux, rassurez-vous.
Ce qui est un peu enquiquinant avec cette histoire,
c’est qu’on a vraiment pensé que la réforme allait complètement révolutionner le traitement qu’on fait aux animaux,
alors que c’était plus une déclaration d’intention qu’autre chose.
Et c’est peut-être aussi une façon de faire plaisir aux associations de protection animale.
Alors, c’est bien chouette les réformes juridiques, mais si c’est juste pour le symbole, on n’est pas bien avancé.
L’un des sénateurs s’opposant à la réforme a posé une question que je trouve pour ma part très pertinente :
“une loi à vocation symbolique est-elle vraiment normative ?”
Regarde Glitch, elle est juste là. Elle est juste là Shirley.
Si tu veux la voir, elle est là, elle est juste en train de dormir au frais.
Tu veux la voir ? Ça va te calmer ? Tu veux.
Elle est juste là.
On parlait de la notion de catégorie sui generis juste avant, et vous allez me dire : mais pourquoi on ne considérerait pas l’animal comme une catégorie sui generis ?
Très bonne question, je vous remercie de me la poser, je vois que vous suivez bien.
Ca pourrait être une solution un peu tentante,
mais en réalité elle ne changerait pas grand chose à notre problème,
puisque je ne pense pas qu’à l’heure actuelle,
on puisse entreprendre une révolution juridique où on interdirait la vente d’animaux,
le fait de pouvoir en détenir ou de les manger.
Un tel bouleversement ne peut pas arriver en une seule réforme et savoir si c’est souhaitable ou non,
là ça dépend de vos convictions personnelles et on sort un peu du droit pur.
En fait, si on commence à créer des exceptions
(puisque la catégorie sui generis est une exception),
on va globalement complexifier tout notre droit.
Parce que vous pouvez trouver plein d’autres exemples qui mériteraient peut-être une catégorie particulière,
mais il y a un moment où il faut essayer de classer le plus sobrement possible, sinon on se perd !
Déjà, les sénateurs qui avaient refusé l’ajout de la mention “être doué de sensibilité”
avançaient que cela avait tendance à complexifier le statut de l’animal dans les textes,
et sur ce point, je les rejoins.
Les règles qui régissent le droit de l’animal sont complètement éclatées partout :
droit pénal, droit des biens, droit de la responsabilité, droit de l’environnement, droit rural etc.
Donc pour comprendre quelque chose à la fin, ça devient VRAIMENT pas simple.
Il existe bien un “Code de l’animal”, mais ce n’est pas une codification “officielle” si j’ose dire.
C’est l’oeuvre d’universitaires qui ont tenté de mettre un peu d’ordre dans tout ça,
en rassemblant tous les textes éparpillés mais il n’a pas la valeur d’un code civil ou d’un code pénal.
Pour le coup, il serait peut-être intéressant de reprendre l’ensemble de ces textes pour le regrouper officiellement au même endroit,
pour des questions de lisibilité et puis, ça permettrait de montrer aussi que oui, les animaux disposent bien de droits particuliers,
et ça n’entrerait pas vraiment en contradiction avec la qualification de “bien”.
De façon assez ironique, vous en conviendrez,
cet ajout d’être doué de sensibilité était plus globalement contenu dans une loi de simplification du droit
comme on a tous les ans maintenant.
Sauf que les juristes ne sont pas très friendly avec ces lois de simplification
qui généralement compliquent plus qu’autre chose des notions qui étaient pourtant
claires et bien établies,
en créant des principes, des exceptions, des exceptions à l’exception et des exceptions à l’exception de l’exception ...
On a aussi un peu l’impression que l’animal n’était pas protégé avant ça alors que c’est complètement faux.
Vous pouvez balancer une chaise contre un mur, personne ne viendra vous embêter, à part peut être vos voisins parce-que ça fait du bruit, mais un chat...
c’est autre chose.
En France, la première loi de protection animale, elle date de 1850.
On a littéralement protégé les animaux avant de limiter le travail des enfants,
c’est quand même un peu inattendu !
Intitulée “loi Grammont”, elle punit d’une amende les mauvais traitements envers les animaux domestiques…
mais en public seulement !
Le député Grammont, celui à l’origine de la loi, avait une réelle sensibilité pour la cause animale, en particulier pour les chevaux.
A l’origine, il souhaitait que les mauvais traitements dans leur globalité soient punis, pas seulement ceux en public !
Mais pour que ça soit accepté, on a dû mettre de l’eau dans notre vin et restreindre ça au cadre public.
Ca a changé totalement l’esprit de la loi.
Les députés voulaient punir les abus sur les animaux,
non pas par charité,
mais parce qu’on considérait que ça pouvait avoir une influence néfaste sur les êtres humains.
Cette conception était plus ancrée dans son temps.
Une décision de la Cour Suprême de l’Etat du Missouri, datant de 1887, expliquait que  :
« La cruauté envers les animaux manifeste une nature vicieuse et dégradée
et elle tend inévitablement à la cruauté envers les hommes. »
On applique la même logique en France.
Donc, punir les actes de mauvais traitements sur les animaux mais seulement en public,
ça a pour conséquence que l’application de la loi reste en pratique très limitée.
Fallait bien un début quoi...
Ceci dit, en cas de récidive, c’était l’emprisonnement automatique !
Ça montre quand même que cette infraction était considérée comme grave.
Saviez-vous que dans les années 1950, on est passé pas loin de l’abolition de la corrida,
puisque ça tombait complètement dans le champ de la loi Grammont.
La Cour de Cassation avait elle-même reconnu que la corrida constituait un mauvais traitement,
et la Cour de cassation, quand elle dit un truc,
généralement ça va amener des conséquences assez importantes.
Rétropédalage du législateur, et pof, en 1951, la loi “Ramanory-Sourbet” nait,
permettant de considérer la corrida comme une exception tolérable et parfaitement légale.
En 1959, on abroge la loi Grammont pour élargir le champ d’application,
notamment pour que les mauvais traitements commis dans le privé puissent aussi être condamnés.
C’est la loi Michelet, sûrement l’une des lois les plus importantes en matière de protection animale
puisqu’on protège l’animal pour lui-même, et non pas seulement pour ne pas choquer la sensibilité du public.
Et en 1963, un décret va alourdir les peines qui étaient déjà prévues.
Le Code rural et de la pêche maritime va reconnaître par la suite que
“ Tout animal étant un être sensible doit être placé par son propriétaire dans des conditions compatibles avec les impératifs biologiques de son espèce”.
C’est l’article L. 214-1, comme ça vous savez d’où vient le nom de cette célèbre association.
Pour illustration, en septembre 2015, on a entendu parler d'un jeune qui avait tué volontairement les 3 chats de sa mère.
Il a été condamné à 6 mois d'emprisonnement, une obligation de soins et l'interdiction de détenir un animal.
Autre exemple plus récent, en janvier 2020, un homme a été condamné à 1 an de prison, dont 6 mois ferme,
pour avoir poignardé à mort un chien.
L’une des parties civiles, Stéphane Lamart pour la Société Nationale de Défense des Animaux
remarque à ce sujet qu'on commence à avoir de plus en plus de peine d’emprisonnement
pour les actes de cruauté envers les animaux.
Ce qui prouve que les magistrats prennent conscience de leurs droits et de l’opinion publique.
En matière de cruauté animale, les gens sont souvent très créatifs mais je ne veux pas vous citer les affaires les plus sordides et sadiques,
car si vous êtes ici, je suppose que vous aimez bien les animaux, et puis moi ça me rend un peu triste de lire tout ça.
Tu vois ce que tu racontes au niveau de tes trucs-là. Ça me fait beaucoup penser à la notion d’image de marque
et la perception du public.
C’est ça qui est intéressant dans ce dont tu parles ici.
Dans le cas des marques, même si là, on n’est pas dans le cas d’une marque. Dans le cas des marques, ça arrive souvent qu’elles s’approprient des causes.
Quand une marque va s’approprier une cause, elle va forcément faire en sorte que ça booste les ventes
auprès des consommateurs qui sont en accord avec ces valeurs.
Et là forcément, on se demande un peu si ce n’est pas un peu hypocrite,
un petit peu mercantile comme stratégie, ce n’est pas très propre finalement comme attention.
Même si dans les actes, ça paraît beau, l’intention derrière n’est pas forcément très saine.
C’est par exemple ce genre de trucs que l’on va appeler le greenwashing. C’est l’exemple le plus connu.
Dans ton cas, avec cette loi sur la sensibilité des animaux, même si ce n’est pas une marque, pour moi, on a des trucs très similaires.
Les associations qui ont un petit peu poussé le truc pour que cette loi passe,
forcément, il y a des retombées médiatiques, c’est comme si elles avaient fait une victoire.
Ça leur donne une super belle image. C’est genre “ regardez, ça ne sert pas à rien ce qu’on fait.
On fait des choses, il se passe des choses. Y a des pas en avant, c’est merveilleux.”
Et au niveau de la loi qu’on n’ennuie un petit peu : “il faudrait faire des trucs et tout”. Ils font une concession : “Bah oui, regardez, on a fait ça.”
Donc finalement, tout le monde parait gentil, c’est beau, tout le monde fait des choses.
Et au niveau des retombées dans la presse, t’as les défenseurs des animaux qui vont voir
des articles passes en mode oh cool, on a gagné un truc. On a fait un pas en avant. On a gagné quelque chose.
Donc même si en vrai, ça parait être une part bien plus grande que ça ne l’est, parce que derrière, c’est vrai que c’est du vide.
Symboliquement, il se passe quand même quelque chose au niveau de ce que ça transmets en terme d’image et de valeur.
Donc voilà, c’est beau. Pas comme ce que tu fais, ça a l’air vraiment dégueulasse.
Toutes ces condamnations, ce n'est pas sur le fondement de l'article 515-14, où on explique que l'animal est doué de sensibilité
mais bien sur les dispositions pénales, donc bien plus vieilles, qui condamnent les mauvais traitements faits aux animaux.
Le droit français fait aussi pas mal de progrès en reconnaissant que le propriétaire d’un animal peut recevoir des dommages et intérêts,
au titre du préjudice moral ou du préjudice d’affection lié à la perte d’un animal.
En cas de divorce très conflictuel, le juge va devoir décider qui va garder le chien,
et va prendre sa décision avec plusieurs critères, comme la situation financière, qui apporte les soins,
est-ce-qu’il y a un enfant dans  l’équation qui est très attaché à l’animal, etc.
C’est bien la preuve qu’on reconnaît un statut particulier à l’animal
qu’on ne le considère pas comme un vulgaire tabouret ou un guéridon sans valeur !
Il y a évidemment plein d’autres réformes juridiques depuis,
mais vous faire une chronologie complète risque d’être un peu long et chiant, on va pas se mentir,
et la loi Grammont et Michelet, c’est clairement celles qu’il faut retenir.
Donc, souvenez-vous  que lorsqu’une réforme juridique est annoncée,
il faut se pencher plus concrètement sur son contenu.
Quand on n’est pas juriste de formation, c’est assez difficile d’accès,
mais il arrive que la presse donne la parole à des spécialistes de la question
ou que des juristes donnent des explications sur certains réseaux sociaux.
Il n’est vraiment pas rare de voir des effets d’annonce pour instaurer telle ou telle nouveauté
qu’en pratique, on a mis en place depuis plusieurs années !
Mais il y a un souci à mes yeux, et là, c’est d’un point de vue éthique.
Je trouve ça très étrange de dire “l’animal est considéré comme un être doué de sensibilité”, sans faire de distinction entre les animaux.
Donc techniquement, selon le droit, ils sont TOUS doués de sensibilité,
De la fourmi à la baleine.
Et pourtant, cette disposition ne rentre pas du tout en conflit avec le fait d’envoyer des animaux à l’abattoir,
ce que je trouve un poil paradoxal.
Je vous rassure tout de suite, le but c’est pas de culpabiliser les gens qui consomment de la viande
puisque j’en consomme moi-même.
Ce qui me gêne juste, c’est que le droit manque beaucoup de rigueur et de cohérence dans son écriture
en instaurant une protection à double vitesse.
En gros, protéger les animaux de compagnie et puis bah les autres…
Ce qui me gêne principalement avec cette nouvelle définition d'êtres doués de sensibilité, c'est qu'on sous-entend du coup que certains animaux sont supérieurs à d'autres.
En France, il est considéré comme choquant de manger un chien (et c’est même interdit) alors qu'une vache, c'est totalement légal.
On n’a légalement pas le droit d’étouffer une colonie d’abeilles, qui sont précieuses pour notre biodiversité,
mais il n’y a pas de dispositions similaires pour les vers de terre, alors qu’ils sont indispensables pour préserver nos sols.
Où se fait la distinction ?
On protège certains animaux domestiques « communs » mais ceux que nous avons l'habitude de consommer, comme le bétail ou les animaux de ferme ne sont pas protégés de la même façon.
Je ne cherche pas à culpabiliser qui que ce soit sur ses choix de consommation.
Mais il a été prouvé qu'une vache était un être très sensible ayant des liens très forts avec son veau par exemple.
Quand on sait ça, est-ce-que ce n'est pas un peu hypocrite de proclamer que c'est un être doué de sensibilité mais de l'envoyer à l’abattoir ensuite ?
Quand on gave un canard pour faire du foie gras, tout d'un coup, l'animal n'est plus doué de sensibilité ?
On protège des animaux, mais quelques-uns seulement... c'est complètement contradictoire et très fragile sur le plan juridique.
Si on veut être cohérent, il faudrait aller jusqu'au bout du raisonnement encore une fois…
Je ne parle même pas des animaux sauvages, parce que cet amendement ne concerne que les animaux domestiques.
En gros, l’éléphant n’a pas de sensibilité, visiblement, si on résume.
Et pourtant, la science nous a prouvé que c’était absolument faux.
Quand tu parles de sensibilité, tu parles de quoi là ?
On sait pas, la loi ne le précise pas.
Alors je vais parler de sensibilité à la douleur, parce que c’est hyper intéressant en biologie ça.
Parce que la sensibilité à la douleur, c’est vraiment subjectif.
T’es la seule à savoir si tu souffres et combien en fait.
Si tu vas chez le médecin, il va te demander d’estimer sur une échelle de 0 à 10 combien tu souffres.
Il ne peut pas te foutre un instrument quelque part et dire tu souffres à 5,3.
Ça ne marche pas comme ça.
Du coup, avec les animaux, comment tu peux savoir ? Tu ne peux pas leur demander : “et là, tu souffres ?”.
Pour communiquer avec un animal, c’est extrêmement difficile.
Là, il y a une solution qu’a trouvée une branche de la biologie qui s’appelle l’éthologie, qui s’intéresse au comportement animal.
Eux, ce qu’ils font, c’est qu’ils essaient de regarder si d’une part, il y a une même structure chez les animaux que chez nous, qui sont responsables de la sensibilité à la douleur.
Donc, c’est, un système nerveux, des récepteurs spécifiques à la douleur, ce genre de trucs là.
Et puis, d’autre part, ils observent leur comportement pour voir s’il y a certains comportements qui trahissent une douleur.
Donc, par exemple, ça peut être un cri d’alerte spécifique, le fait de se renfermer un peu sur soi-même, éviter le contact avec les autres, ce genre de trucs.
Et ça, ça permet de voir que la plupart des mammifères sont sensibles à la douleur et même certains vertébrés.
Pour les poissons, on a des soupçons, on ne sait pas encore très bien.
Mais il y a tout de même un défaut à cette approche, c’est l’anthropomorphisme.
En gros, c’est le fait d’attribuer des comportements humains à des animaux.
Genre, si tu vois un animal qui boite, tu dis : “ohlala le pauvre il a mal”. Alors que si ça se trouve, il n’a pas mal du tout. On ne sait pas.
Ça, c’est vraiment un grand biais dans l’étude du comportement, et si on pouvait éviter l’anthropomorphisme, ça ferait beaucoup de bien à la science.
Alors, on est bien d’accord.
Clairement, il y a certaines urgences en matière de protection animale.
On protège déjà les animaux des mauvais traitements, on peut les retirer à leur propriétaire, faire fermer des élevages abusifs...
Bien sûr, il y aurait d’autres choses à faire.
Par exemple, en Suisse, pour avoir un chien,
il faut suivre quelques cours avec un éducateur avant !
Et il est interdit de détenir un seul cochon d’inde, car c’est un animal grégaire, il a besoin d’un compagnon !
Alors bon, les droits des cochons d’inde, ça vous fera sûrement sourire, mais en vrai, ces dispositions sont très justes et pertinentes.
On s’intéresse aux besoins des espèces, on met des contraintes qui permettent de vérifier que les personnes sont bien responsables et conscientes lors de l’adoption,
donc à terme c’est un moyen de lutter contre la maltraitance et l’abandon des animaux.
Et ça fait complètement écho à l’article L.214-1 qui dit je le rappelle :
“Tout animal étant un être sensible doit être placé par son propriétaire dans des conditions compatibles avec les impératifs biologiques de son espèce”.
Sauf que pour reprendre le modèle suisse, là on a une vraie application, concrète et adaptée, et ça c’est très pertinent et beaucoup moins vague !
Il y aurait d’autres combats à mener, comme celui sur l'interdiction des animaux dans les cirques ou encore, l’interdiction du broyage  des poussins vivants par exemple,
puisqu’à l’heure où je tourne cette vidéo, bah c’est toujours possible.
Et quand bien même l’interdiction du broyage serait effectivement planifiée fin 2021 comme annoncé, on ne va pas se mentir, on a bien pris notre temps !
Donc bon, être vivant doué de sensibilité…
Est-ce-que ce rajout d'être doué de sensibilité dans le code civil a changé les mentalités ?
Concrètement, non.
Il faut s'interroger sur nos rapports aux animaux,
sur nos modes de consommation.
Le droit peut initier des changements dans la société, mais il n’est pas suffisant en lui-même.
Il doit effectivement condamner les abus sur les animaux,
mais il y a tout un travail de sensibilisation à effectuer,
dont les juristes ne peuvent pas endosser la seule responsabilité.
Je me pose donc la question :
ne vaudrait-il pas mieux veiller à faire respecter les règles juridiques déjà à notre disposition
plutôt que d'opérer des changements peu significatifs ?
C'est ça qui fait bouger les choses, c'est ça qui nous permet d'ancrer dans les consciences communes que oui, un animal ça se respecte.
Je n’ai pas le temps d’aborder tout le droit des animaux parce que c’est quelque chose de plutôt dense.
Donc, si le sujet vous intéresse, je vous conseille vraiment ce bouquin “Introduction au droit de l’animal” que je vous conseille, parce qu’il est plutôt accessible pour des gens qui n’ont pas fait de droit.
Donc si le sujet vous passionne, n’hésitez pas.
Merci d’avoir regardé cette vidéo jusqu’au bout.
J’espère qu’elle vous aura plu, on pourra se retrouver sur Discord pour en discuter tous ensemble.
En attendant, n’hésitez pas à liker, à vous abonner et à partager la vidéo.
Et sur ce, on vous dit, à bientôt !
Nan mais, Shirley et Glitch, c’était vraiment une histoire d’amour.
Fallait les voir ensemble ces deux-là.
Il s’en remettra, ne t'inquiète pas.
Oui, je ne me fais pas de souci pour lui. Je l’ai croisé tout à l’heure avec un énorme steak dans la bouche. Il n’avait pas l’air malheureux.
Un steak ?
Bah oui, tu sais les trucs qu’on décongèle là.
Pourquoi on ferait décongeler des steaks alors que ce soir on mange sushi ?
Je suis actuellement en live sur Twitch pour pouvoir débriefer l'épisode sur les animaux avec vous.
Je n'ai pas de chat, on va faire tout comme,
avec cette petite chose adorable.
Et puis on se retrouve sur Twitch.
À tout de suite.